hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast
I'm just checking in on you
and I'm driving I'm driving because I'm
all Billy busy day oh there's an Amazon
Prime truck that's sort of like a UPS
truck I thought they only had the
Sprinter Vents and I'll look to my right
there's a Dodge Ram TRX in velocity Ford
velocity blue figure that one out
that that looks like their answer to the
Raptor
like we can make a really loud truck
that serves no [__] purpose
unless you take it out to the desert
and go Baja racing
um oh whatever maybe somebody likes a
truck like that I have no idea I think
my truck's showing up today the truck I
don't need
I'm doing my part
when it comes to capitalism I went out
and bought something I didn't need
strictly for an image
nowadays it's something something I
always wanted
I always wanted a full-size [__]
pickup truck even though I have a small
size brain there you go all right can I
can I just have that that guy just
sitting on a bicycle staring at his
phone
just sitting there is he waiting for
somebody else to ride his bike with
I mean I'm in a car on my phone this
guy's on a bicycle like he's taking it
to the next level
if he hits a pedestrian does he get sued
or does he get a pass because he's you
know he did it in a green way
Oh Billy gonna make the light oh Billy
gonna make the light yeah
there's a place that's gonna go out of
business soon sometimes you can just see
you just look at the paint on the
outside of a store and you're like that
[__] place does not have a prayer
speaking about not having a prayer the
[__] Bruins last night Jesus Christ
we got our goddamn asses whipped
by the Florida Panthers
um you know because it's the playoffs
all of these people all excited they won
the most regular season games than ever
in the regular season
it's like it's the regular season I've
been saying this
since everybody was talking about Peyton
Manning
you know was a better quarterback than
Tom Brady and I just said I was like the
playoffs is what counts
all right you want 500 yards against the
[__]
Atlanta Falcons in November
or do you want a [__] trophy in
February
so um historically speaking whoever's
won the President's trophy I don't think
they really win the cup so I don't
understand what all the excitement's
about you got to win 16 goddamn games
and we are a uh a fast finesse team so
Florida is going to get physical with us
God damn it that's what they did
they got in the locker room
came up with the Olivia Newton John
Let's Get Physical physical I actually
missed most of the game I'm not gonna
lie to you I went to an event last night
with my wife
you know because you don't just go out
with your wife you go to events
um I went to a fashion show
I swear to God if there's anything
that's less don't you even [__] think
about cutting back in here you [__]
Tesla [__]
you [__] Tesla [__] you just think
you're just gonna drive around now
that's not how it works there lady
that's right that's right looking over
your shoulder like what is Chevrolet
dead Chevrolet however you say that word
there's a guy who should have stopped
jogging [__] three blocks ago
jogging has got to be like the dumbest
thing you could ever do
it's like hey I'm young I have good hips
and knees and feet
wouldn't be great to have the hips knees
ankles and feet of a [__]
eight-year-old I think I'll take up
jogging
I will say something about that guy at
least he was jogging on the sidewalk
you know something happened during the
pandemic where people like they walk and
they jog now in the street
and like out in the street like they're
daring you to [__] hit them
um oh [__] now I'm in the wrong lane is
the Tesla going to get me back is the
Tesla gonna get me back do I need to go
into sport mode here oh Dad's going into
sport mode what's gonna happen next
tuzzy gonna start singing along to
Aerosmith
um
yeah so I went to a fashion show last
night at the Hollywood Bowl
um
this thing uh for this clothing line
fear of God and I gotta tell you it's
one of the coolest events I ever went to
because I was sitting there going like
it's gonna be at the Hollywood Bowl
and like they're just gonna walk down
the runway like how long could this
thing last and they turned it into a
whole friggin show
it was like cinematic there was social
commentary it was the history of the
country the whole freaking thing it was
all there the whole the entire gamut of
a mo oh he was making a left
and I get to go the entire gamut of
emotions
um
and what I loved was the clothes were
actually something that you could wear
I was kind of joking with
with the lovely Nia last night I was
like you know who who might have been
like uh
like disappointed the only people who
could have been disappointed you know
those people that think they're like
they're into fashion and it's just like
no you just threw a bunch of [__]
together that doesn't [__] match
I have on one Chuck Taylor and one
wingtip shoe commenting on you know
classism oh is that what you're doing uh
I thought you would just dress like a
jerk off
whenever they do that then but if you
gotta go like that bolt you know as I
sat there toy looking at like somebody
who shops at Hot Topic
you know no matter how much my wife
tried to make it look like I was also
into fashion I'm not which we all know
all right
I am like
if I didn't have kids I would I would
still shop at the mall
I go to the mall I like them all
it's got all the stores there
I can look at stuff I can hold it in my
hand it isn't this [__] where I gotta
like
you know
figure out the European size you know
that's the thing I [__] hate about
the internet
you look at something you're like yeah I
think that fits or I think that's gonna
look good
and then it shows up and you look like
an absolute [__] jerk off and then
what do you do with it
that's what happened to me I bought one
of those Mitchell and Ness
football jerseys
I bought a Fran Tarkington
Minnesota Viking the all purple one
right and I got it and I was excited he
was my favorite quarterback in the 70s
and uh
I put it on and I look like a [__]
jerk off
you know
and I had that thing for years until I
finally gave it I gave it away to
somebody on the podcast I think
some
poor bastard that's a Vikings fan
how soon before they change that name
excuse me Vikings didn't they like rape
and pillage
why is there a white man with beautiful
blonde flowing hair
you know
I mean the Vikings hello rape culture
um
anyway
I was [__] trash day look at the
goddamn barrels are all out
less parking
less parking more barrels we got the
green ones
for the for the clippings we got the
black ones for trash and then we have
the blue ones for recycling and three
different trucks come by and pick them
up and then all of them are dumped in
the ocean
you know what those things are like the
trash barrels the different colors it's
like when you watch one of those those
how to cook shows
you know and there's some [__] you
know
upbeat
chick with their [__] white teeth
today we're going to make one of our
favorite dishes I just love the
summertime because the summer times for
me means kiwis are in season right and
they just [__] there's that stupid
[__] piano
of someone who just had a traumalous
childhood every day they were encouraged
they were told that they were loved and
this is just you know major chords are
being played right
it's a little zippy a little Zippy
[__] tune with this [__] you know
kitchen that gets a lot of light
right
and then she comes out there and she's
hot but not in a hoary way but you know
she swallows and not just food right
sorry I'm just saying that's that's sort
of like that's that's the recipe right
so they always have the whole thing
laid out
you know a little bit of turmeric a
little bit of paprika and they always
have them in those little [__] bowls
and they go
and then they just [__] mix it up and
they got the whole the whole thing like
comes together in eight minutes and it
makes it feel like you know like you can
do this and it's not gonna take four
hours those trash barrels
they're like the trash the garbage
version of one of those [__] TV shows
we got our cycling over here we have our
clippings that add a little zest
and here we have the straight up trash
and then they dump them all in the same
Bowl
look at this convicted drunk driver you
know you know a drunk driver might be a
you know someone who can't afford a car
uh you know what yeah that guy looks
like he's had a rough life anytime I see
a guy in street clothes
you know riding a bicycle it's like oh
you got busted you got a DUI you got a
d-week
dude you hear about [__] Fitzy
he was driving Smitty home over the
[__] Kelly's house
he was drinking sambuca all [__]
night he got pulled over
[__] Sadie was like if you've been
drinking tonight he goes what are you
[__] me I'm [__] shattered
kid blew a [__] three flat
was still standing they couldn't believe
it they almost let him go
um because it was so impressed
anyway I'm working my way over here I
gotta do I gotta shoot something
uh oh Billy thespian here this is an
easy one though
Oh beardless Billy though
you don't try to do something a little
different on camera who is that who is
that did the Michelin Man lose some
weight
who is that bald clean shaven man
look at that [__] old guy just
walking around with his hand in his
pocket
his whole I've seen some things
I've seen some goddamn things you
[__] think you got it bad
um
this is what I'm doing today I'm going
to handle this [__] and then after I
handle this [__] I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go fly and chop
um beautiful clear day out here
I think that's going to be my day
not hurting anybody maybe grab a taco
along the way Celtics up two games to
none
two games to nil
baiting down the [__] Atlantic Hawks
Atlantic the Atlanta Hawks like we
should be
um
Bruins I'm [__] I don't know I think
that we're gonna learn this is my
prediction we're going to learn a lot
from that loss
because you don't learn anything when
you win it's the losses where you learn
stuff I think we're going to learn a lot
from that and then uh we're gonna kick
the [__] out of them
in game three we're gonna give me all
right there Fred
do you think anybody's gonna even show
up for that game down in Florida
like what percentage of people in Miami
actually know
you know that they have a hockey team I
know that they know they have a baseball
team
because I think they're always going
like no man it's too [__] hot
I don't want to do that
or do they have an enclosed one
I don't [__] know
anyway this is this is one of the this
is why I don't do podcasts while driving
I'm trying to think of stuff to talk
about while I'm like looking at [__] all
at the same time I'm on a very
depressing Street right now this is one
of these eyesore streets
that pretty soon somebody's going to
come in ah there's a couple right there
and [__] build new houses that are
always like twice the goddamn size
underrated
underrated out here one of those little
bungalows
you know you don't have to buy as much
[__]
is everybody's Fried Chicken Place world
famous you know I've done a lot of
traveling I don't think anybody have
said hey have you ever been to [__]
Gus's
I've always wanted to come to America I
actually like Gus's Fried Chicken why am
I shedding on them
oh look at this guy with his Ford truck
he's got some skulls and then he's got
two Pistons
is the crossbones
10th Generation step side forward
it's got the little cover in the back
jeans and a sweatshirt
with the [__] I actually work for a
living work boots not the Timberlands
indicating that you have a new album
about to drop back in the day
he actually has actually not a fiction
Public Storage
there's a [__] show right there
I guarantee you there's nothing in there
worth keeping
getting my kitchen remodeled I put
everything in storage oh yeah did you
miss it
did you miss any of that stuff
you know it just yeah the greater you
know what I missed the grater
we're back to talking about cooking
all right here's a classic
strip mall
in Los Angeles you can get donuts
Vape massage dentist
or get insurance
[Laughter]
I mean I think can [__] handle your
entire day
I actually met somebody really cool last
night and they were saying like you know
what I don't like about La in New York
you can stumble into a good meal
you can't really stumble one into one
out here in LA and I was like that's
what I used to think just start going
into these [__] strip malls
these absolute eyesore strip malls and
you will eventually
you're gonna stumble into something like
the best sushi ever had or the best
Mexican food or the best auto insurance
maybe the best foot doctor
why are these [__] ambulance chasing
lawyers always pointing at me
yeah I'll get you your [__] money
have you been paralyzed from the neck
down and you could make millions can I
make money off of your paralysis
hey you did you get rear-ended huh is
your buttocks in pain I would like to
make my [__] 15 off of your goddamn
pain
um there's actually one out here I swear
to God there's there's a I gotta take a
picture of it it's a cartoon of a lawyer
and he's pointing
first of all my first thought is like
how unsightly is this guy that they
couldn't even just take a picture of him
they had a drum
you know
and uh
the first time I looked at it
at first glance I thought it was Todd
Barry
he looks like Todd Berry if if he never
did comedy
I don't know I don't know what I'm
talking about people I'm just driving
down the road
I need to get a hands-free device like
all these like this guy in this minivan
next to me
this guy seems to have it all figured
out what do I turn here am I turned in
here
you know what's great about this I don't
have to listen to this that [__] lady
going make a turn in three quarters of a
mile make a turn in 700 feet make a turn
in 300 feet turn right here
it's like you don't think I heard you
the first 17 times I'm turning onto a
[__] highway why can't you just say
get on 10 West
probably not her fault you know
what does this say U.S marine for
combating for something or other
it's got to be the spot to beg for money
everybody who seems when you get on a
highway out here
that was a big conspiracy theory dude
they're making like a hundred grand a
year
somebody followed them home he actually
lives in a mansion
it's true dude that is just always
traffic out here look at this [__]
where the [__] are all these people
going that's what the number one thing
you say in La where the [__] are all of
these people going you know not
realizing that you're part of the
problem
like why am I out here I really was
hoping that during
uh the covet
that people oh there you go look at that
there's a Ford F-250 regular cab
eighth generation not that four to a
stupid [__] with the little three foot
bed that's a [__] truck right there
beautiful I was hoping during covid
that uh everyone would realize how great
the zoom meeting was
because no one had to get out on the
road and there would be like less
traffic
you know but it turned out it was more
like
a diet like I'm cutting out sugar I'm
done with it I feel better the
inflammation has gone down in my knees
I've gotten back to running
you know I can swallow again
back to that it's called the call back
everybody
but it wasn't
it wasn't
what do you guys think of the mid-engine
Corvette I'm not I'm still haven't
bought into it yet
but I talked about the Corvette well I
like the long [__] nose and it was
our version of a super car now it just
looks it looks European looks too
[__] European to me and not only that
it looks like a poor man's uh
like Ferrari where I thought before it
had its own it had its own vibe oh [__]
I gotta get off here excuse me thank you
thank you all right
yeah I thought it had it's its own Vibe
you know the nice long
[__] nose
two seats you know basically has a back
seat but no one game you're not giving
anybody a ride
right
the Corvette always said I need some me
time that's what I always liked about it
I also feel like it's a shorter car now
I don't know
you know what some purists would
probably say that we ripped off that old
Jaguar
that had that little [__] door in the
back
is that the xjs is that what it is
um
oh man you know what I think the winner
is over out here
and it goes right to Summer it's already
starting to look bleak
this is a weird time of year
you know when it's cold out and
everything this is such a beautiful city
but once once it gets hot
you know what I mean
look at that one guy one guy with a tent
it's got this whole [__] underpass to
himself
or maybe that's how they do it but one
guy goes in if nobody [__] with them
everybody else brings the rest of their
tent
I saw this great video the other day
this guy went to Home Depot
you know all those guys that hang out
looking for work
he brought three of them to Disneyland
and they had a great time and one of the
guys actually said
I never had a toy growing up it's one of
the saddest things I ever heard
and then everybody was like writing in
like yeah we got to help people like
that blah blah blah be nice if there was
more of that
that's what you feel when you watch the
video
but then when you pull up at Home Depot
you're like I don't know these [__]
people
[Laughter]
I have no idea what this [__] guy did
has done he could be the greatest person
in the world
or he could have just [__] killed
somebody
I guess that's kind of what everybody
anytime you let somebody in the house
that guy needs to raise the seat on that
[__] bicycle
Jesus Christ he's gonna knee himself in
the chin
you know it's a pet peeve of mine
someone who doesn't need a cane
and [__] still has one anyway
look at that thing he's just like
that's like someone who quit smoking and
they still walk around with a cigarette
because they got that [__] oral
fixation
a lot of oral fixation in this this
week's
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday Morning podcast
um
actually have no idea how much time I've
done I did 14 minutes then I had to stop
so I could get off the highway safely
I've done 21 minutes well look at that
look at me
I'm multitasking
another thing I don't like I don't like
people who just sort of have their arm
hanging out the window the passenger
side I feel like it's disrespectful to
the driveway to the driver driveway to
the driver
I'm in the wrong lane hang on a second
can I come over please
oh look at me
I'm turning on Obama Boulevard
he's already got a street named after
him
that's pretty [__] good
they must have George Bush Boulevard in
in Houston they got to have that George
Bush
you know senior and Junior
like Santa Monica and little Santa
Monica
I'm gonna look that up you think there's
a Bill Clinton Boulevard in [__]
Little Rock Arkansas
there is there's got to be some titty
bars on it that would be perfect they
put it right down in the red light
district he wouldn't even give a [__]
I'm surprised he didn't have it lead to
an island
[Laughter]
you know that is one of those [__] up
things
bought that whole me too you uh uh
[__] movement like
you know
I guess because that was like world
leaders and there's no way to crack that
because the claims people were making
and God knows a lot of that [__] just
became accusations
like I saw people get canceled they went
on one bad date this guy goes to [__]
Epstein Island allegedly like 30 [__]
times and everybody's ah
nothing to see there hey played the
saxophone on a talk show
he wore sunglasses and he
he played Fleetwood Mac you know come on
it's Billy
Oh Billy let him go
you know I've never been to a Del Taco
I must have driven by 40 000 of those
[__] things
I always felt like Del Taco was like
like the Frank Stallone of Taco Plick
it's it's Taco Bell like if you're gonna
do like [__]
fast food Mexican Cuisine you go to Taco
Bell right whatever oh this is where the
young kids go come at me
come at me
actually how about this educate me if
I'm gonna get
a bastardized version of Mexican Cuisine
should I go to
um
Del Taco or uh
Taco Bell I'm not going to go to either
one of them
here's a person with a cane not using it
also wearing a tuxedo shirt
another guy carrying a folding chair
Kentucky Fried Chicken
for some reason if it's cold I can eat
it if it's actually heated up
I feel like I'm gonna die
I feel horrible I feel like I ate a
[__] I feel like I ate the kernels uh
shoe
um
all right we're getting closer here
people I might have to [__] I'm gonna
I'm gonna do the ad reads a little bit
after this why don't we I'm going to do
this in segments
is that a Toyota it is a Toyota look at
that
1970s Toyota
oh those Jeeps called that they had back
then
I don't know whatever
spend the Thursday afternoon this is
like Comedians and Cars drinking coffee
except I'm by myself
and I already had a cup of coffee
cup of coffee in the
um all right
I think that's it
Lakers 1-1
against the Memphis Grizz are they going
to go out in the first round and then
everybody on the Lakers is going to cry
and be like we need more free
why don't can't we buy the people off
the Grizzlies that beat us
um
[__] franchise
Jesus Christ you know what that
franchise is like like they like those
evil redheaded people not to [__] on my
own people the LA Lakers are like those
evil [__] redheads in South Carolina
with that [__] evil ginger killed
those people on the boat that's what
they like they just [__] buy their
way out of every goddamn problem
um
all right I gotta I gotta make this
light
Jesus Christ buddy could you [__] car
be any more lime green
what is that a Scion
actually look like a nice person in it
Carl's Jr there's another one I don't
[__] with you know why too much lettuce
too much lettuce not enough dead animal
back in the day I would go to Jack In
The Box I would get the ultimate
cheeseburger but I didn't like the fact
that they didn't put it they didn't put
any ketchup on it
and also the ketchup stunk if I remember
correctly all right I've had enough of
me too well I'll be back in a second
reading some ads
all right it's time for the reads it's
time for the reads
all right what do we got here hey this
Sunday Sunday Sunday Sunday I'm doing a
special LIVE edition of the Monday
Morning podcast tickets will be
available for all Monday Morning podcast
listeners to take pot in the digital
experience no matter where in the world
you call home where in the world do you
call [__] home I will be answering
questions submitted by viewers on the
live chat
April type Jesus like those aren't going
to be insulted
were you always an ugly bastard April
23rd at noon Pacific Standard Time get
your tickets for the digital experience
at
www.moment.com
sorry slash Bill Burr
Bill Burr
um
all right uh Helix everybody
Alex Helix sleep is a premium mattress
brand that provides tailored mattresses
based on your unique sleep preferences
the Helix lineup includes 14 unique
mattresses including a collection of
luxury models ooh
is that is that gold emblazoned
handles on the side of the mattress a
mattress for Big and Tall sleepers and
even a mattress made just for kids ages
3 to 12. so how will you know which
Helix mattress works best for you take
the Helix sleep quiz and find your
perfect mattress in under two minutes
and personalize your mattress and your
personalized mattress is shipped
straight to your door free of charge
Helix knows there's no better way to
test out a new mattress than by sleeping
on it in your own on your in your own
home sorry that's why they offer a
hundred night trial and a 10 to 15 year
warranty to try out your new Helix
mattress
gross try it out man do what you do on
your mattress and after a hundred days
you don't like it uh plus enhanced
cooling features to keep you from
overheating at night
and if your spine needs some extra TLC
they got you every Helix mattress has a
hybrid design combining individually
wrapped steel coils in the base with
premium foam layers on top it's the
perfect combination of comfort and
support plus Helix mattresses are
American made man and come with the 10
to 15 year warranty depending on the
model I love that
I love it we make something here other
than weed and meth you got Shinola and
you got Helix Alex don't want to take my
word for it Helix has been awarded the
number one mattress picked by GQ and
Wired Magazine it's even recommended by
multiple leading Chira practice and
doctors of sleep medicine as a go-to
solution for improving your sleep Helix
is offering up to 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to helixsleep.com
this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix sleep better
sleep
stats now
speaking of starting right now we're
going to listen to this is this has been
the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday Morning podcast thank you
so much for listening while I've been
driving sorry for multitasking uh we got
a little musical interlude picked out by
the always brilliant always tasteful
always wonderful Andrew femalis and then
we'll have a bonus episode of the
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday Morning podcast uh will be
playing right after this that's it have
a great weekend you can't go Bruins go
Celtics go [__] yourself
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday April uh 20th April 20th how you
doing what's going on talking to you
from the road
don't you node
um sorry
I'm in the middle of nowhere man I'm in
[__] Chattanooga Tennessee and I
haven't seen [__] I haven't seen [__]
here yet I ain't seen [__] here yet
um I'm in the middle of the Southern
tour here uh uh traveling on the bus
fueling up next to Truckers
it's a whole other world man whole other
world those truck drivers you know but
you know what I only saw one real fat
one
or someone fatty you know one big guy
was just like dude you need to uh you
need to start jogging some laps around
your truck man that's gotta be the
hardest [__] job to stay in shape
holy [__]
this one guy is [__] sitting there
he's got a dog in there
you know how the [__] do you make any
time when you got a dog I mean do you
gotta [__] pull over every couple
hours right well I guess you gotta get
gas anyways
things gotta take a [__] you know
foreign
anyways this is the Monday morning
podcast this is going to be a [__] up
one because I'm in a silly ass mood and
I have no idea what's going on in the
world right now I know that there were
some refugees that floated over on some
little boat not a little boat like 700
people oh God I [__] hate those
stories they always skip the part too
where they go there's some bodies being
seen they don't never talk about all
that Quint from Jaws [__] the amount
that we're treading water and got eaten
by sharks dude you know how bad a
country has to be for you to [__]
take your chances doing that
this you wouldn't get me out on a
[__] Lake
I I don't I I do not [__] with I go into
pools I want to pull all goddamn day
[__] that I wouldn't go in a pond
[__] that
these goddamn people trying to cross the
Mediterranean Sea I don't even know
where they were coming from
Jesus Christ now how do you as a
dictator at that point do you how do you
not know at that point like hey maybe I
uh maybe I should ease up a little bit
on the people here
they're [__]
they're trying to cross the
Mediterranean on a goddamn hoopty
people [__] boogie boards and [__] at
that point you got to know you know if
even if you didn't give a [__] about him
you'd have to be thinking like
um I think there's going to be an
attempt made on my life pretty soon
you know considering 700 people just
died you figured they got to have a
bunch of people that loved him right say
three people loved all those people
there's 2100 people that want to [__]
kill me extra today as a dictator
um
you know probably help if I actually
look to see which one it was the only
dictator I knew in that got beaten to
death by [__] from AutoZone
remember that guy Gaddafi he got beaten
to death with like [__]
car batteries and antennas walking
around with half his [__] uniform on
that was a travesty you know what I mean
that was like worse than seeing Emmett
Smith
playing for the Arizona Cardinals you
know that you know like when you just
see like uh me and Rosie talk about that
Patrick Newark Patrick Ewing when he
played for like Orlando just seen him in
that uniform seeing Gaddafi walking
around with half his boy scout uniform
on begging for his life
not like I was a fan but you know it's
like you gotta you know you gotta know
when to get out of Show Business and
that that includes being a dictator you
got to know you got to be able to feel
it you got to be sitting there going all
right people are leaving this country
and [__] boats just to get away from me
how much longer are they gonna put put
up with me how much longer can I can I
keep the facade going that I can beat
everybody's ass one-on-one here in this
country
you know what I mean
I don't know man
hang on a sec let me find can we at
least have the decency for the victims
to know where that went you know that's
terrible that's terrible that that
happened to them but I gotta tell you
it's good for the baby seals you know
what I mean because that's 700 less
people eating fish now
and they actually fed fish
what they did was tremendous you know
have you guys seen that story like
there's like baby seals washing up on
the ocean I mean on the ocean washing up
on the beach just because they're
starving to death because the oceans are
so fished out
this is probably a bad thing to bring up
you know when you're sitting there
reading this thing all right London
Rescuers grabbed scrambled I want this
stock [__] thing let me selected
there we go all right where did this
happen
it's being reported from London
Mediterranean
Crossing Europe
to Europe from Africa okay all right
more than 17 vessels were searching for
the survivors oh my God
70 miles off the coast of Libya
now Libya isn't that where Gaddafi used
to [__] cut all his hits and he used
to record out there
only you know the [__] teen idle
sensation out there
I gotta look this up here Libya
Libya dictator D.A tour dictator who do
you got who do you got
more Gaddafi
how the [__] do you take [__] from a guy
named Omar
you have to do it momar said now [__]
him he never looked like he was a badass
did he he just always looked like uh he
just that was just bad casting I'm gonna
I'm gonna vote that guy worst like most
unintimidating like [__] dictator
ever he just looked at his face I don't
know what he looks he just looks like uh
you know what he looked like to me was
uh what's his face uh
oh Christ what's his name
Bobby uh
[__] I'm the worst I gotta get off the
road
the [__] is his name
ah Jesus it's the perfect [__]
analogy too it's gonna tour I'll
remember it I'll remember it by the end
of this
um
anyways I'm just saying the guy's face
he looks you know what it is he looks
like this guy that I know that I can't
remember his [__] name this is going
off the rails over here
um all right anyway so we're on we're on
the southern tour here we did uh we did
Savannah the first night and uh
just a great crowd beautiful city and um
you know the usual [__] we go I mean uh
[__] lighthead we flew out on the
17th because uh we're coming from the
west coast and
we show up you know we don't have a v we
don't have a vehicle we're staying out
by the airport so we're nowhere near
downtown Savannah I didn't see anything
in Savannah I didn't see Old Town I
didn't see [__] I always wanted to go
there I never even got to it because we
were staying way out by the airport and
the bus hadn't shown up yet right
so we say to the lady downstairs right
first of all they [__] check in she
takes my driver's license and as always
just starts typing [__] in I go what are
you doing she goes I'm typing in your
home address and it's just like for what
well just in case you leave something
well if I leave something of value I'll
call you guys
I'll notice and then I'll call you guys
and then you guys of course will say you
couldn't find it because it was of a it
was a value
the housekeeper that you're not paying
[__] is going to keep it there's no
reason for you to [__] take my home
address you're just gonna sell it to
somebody else and make a little bit of
money
so
today I went to go check in the hotel
and she takes my my [__] driver's
license she goes type in I said what are
you doing she goes I'm typing in your
home address and I go uh I don't want
you do to do that
she goes you don't want me to do that I
said yes I don't want you to do that she
goes okay how about just a zip code and
I said no
and she said okay so that's what I
learned today it's [__] optional
[__] [__]
just [__] take your ID just telling
these people to just start [__]
typing your goddamn address in there
what the [__] are you doing
I'm renting a room
here's my credit card here's my ID
saying that's my credit card now [__]
off and give me a room
you got to know where I live
huh
you [__] weirdos I'm telling you
people don't do that don't do that
because they upload it onto their [__]
and then it's just it's just out there
the next thing you know
I don't know what
if you're lucky you're just getting
spammed by a Red Roof Inn
getting [__] sent to you directly
if you're really unlucky
I don't know what happens somebody
[__] steal your identity somebody
shows up at your [__] either way it's
rude
and it's completely [__] unnecessary
and uh and I'll tell you right now I'll
tell you right now this this freckled
face [__] is uh is against it
100 100
um
so anyways so
we say to the lady downstairs at the uh
at the hotel we're like so uh you know
we walk in right I see lawhead lawhead
sees me we obviously know we're going to
start drinking immediately and I ask you
know we walk in is the hotel bar still
open she's like no now it is and it just
closed I'm sorry you want me to go make
you some you're down south we're really
polite and I was like no that's all
right you don't have to make it some is
there a bar nearby and she goes yeah it
is straight and I'm like all right
can you walk there from there she's like
oh now now yeah y'all y'all can't walk
here from hey you can't walk cause it's
too far again why
he gonna get attacked by a wild cat or
something and I was just like all right
well let me look this [__] thing up
and I looked it up it was like it was
like a [__] barely a mile away
you know it's like what do you mean you
can't [__] walk so we [__] walk
over there we literally walk half the
half a mile of the Walk was getting out
of the goddamn
[__] hotel area
and then we just look down the streets
we see lights we see civilization
ah you can't walk down I mean you could
do it but I mean I don't know what would
happen to you so we go all the way down
she didn't even talk like that I just
like the southern accent and [__]
annoying people from where I'm touring
so we [__] head all the way down
there we end up walking to this bar
there's this little band in there guy on
guitar and a guy playing drums they're
both killing it singing all this [__]
from the 90s [__] tremendous
well [__] drinking right
uh the only thing that sucked was they
were giving us shots of Jameson and
glasses that they had just taken out of
the dishwasher so the glass was all
those was between warm and kind of hot
was gross it was making me sick to my
stomach but I kept drinking
um
and I don't know what happened we just
sat there laughing our asses off we were
watching some some game I don't even
know what the [__] we were watching and
next thing you know I really I looked up
and we were the only two people left in
the place
and we were too drunk to [__] walk
back we didn't want to
so uh this the dude
at the bar this gay dude who was wearing
a kilt for whatever [__] reason I
think because it was an Irish bar he
gave us a ride home
so that's how it started
he was a great guy he came walking over
and he just took our [__] beers put
them in paper cups and he just let us
drink it that last little mile on the
way home and then I walked in
to the hotel and I said to the lady you
know hey can you still order room
service is there any way we can order
some service up to the room some some
service room room service stuff she's
like ah now now catches clouds this
catches all right at Clouds I'm sorry
y'all you want me you want me to go
outside go kill pheasant for you I'll
cook it up I'll bread it all deep fried
make you some dumplings we're like no no
that's cool that's cool and I went over
and I bought a bag of [__] potato
chips
I went upstairs and laid in bed drunk
and ate a bag of chips and fell asleep
that's how the tour started remember I
told you guys I was gonna try to not put
on any weight that's how it started
that's what set the [__] tone right
then the next day the goddamn bus pulls
up
right
the bus pulls up and we see that thing
and it's just I don't know we've been
actually been doing pretty good though
as far as um
you know
I went out and I got uh I got some
cereal I got corn checks right I got
some bananas that's my breakfast and
then I got some turkey did all of this
in Walmart so God knows what level of
quality this [__] actually is oh my god
dude you go into a Walmart holy [__] you
cannot believe the loss of Hope in those
[__] people's eyes
this [__] lady this [__] lady when
I went up to the deli
I mean I was just like hey how you doing
I'm [__] turning on the charm hey
what's going on how are you and she just
[__] looking at me
she's like what do you want
just like uh
can I get a pound of that smoked turkey
please she's like
is that it
I was like uh you know come in your real
heart hey how you doing and somebody
just [__] hit you with your attitude
and you immediately got to adjust all
the way down to them you know it's like
the way I lost out on the negotiations
last week on the rug you know and um
so I go from hey how's it going Charlie
uh yeah I'll have some uh have some
turkey
she's like that it
that it that's what she said that it and
I was like uh
I can't get like you know 15 slices of
cheese
you know white cheddar white American
whatever you got
she's like yep
she [__] goes up and just cuts it up
and like I can't even tell you the way
she like handed it to me while just sort
of looking off into the distance down
the aisles
you know and uh just ugh
you know so now you know I'm I'm shaking
it off right
I'm getting some [__] condiments
for the sandwich I got pickles I got my
mustard and I get I get down to the
booze I realized I don't have any hard
stuff so I had to throw in a six a
[__] Blue Moon whatever that's the
best they got here
and these [__] [__]
have the nerf on a Sunday to not let me
buy a six pack of beer the lady took it
away from me I had it on the little
conveyor belt and she's [__] you know
coin checks Boop right half gallon of
two percent milk everything's going fine
and then she goes uh she goes I can't
let you have this and took it away from
me
and said it on the other side of the
register
like I was gonna lunge after it or
something I can't let you have this it's
before 12 30 on a Sunday
and I was just I ate
it's like are we [__] adults here you
already dude I was
the way they [__] treat their
employees there how bad how poorly
Walmart treats their [__] employees
they're gonna have the nerve
to not let people drink before noon they
should be letting those people drink on
the job
how [__] miserable they treat those
damn people
how do I know they treat them miserably
I don't know
I've just heard they have
they won't give me my beer so now I'm
trashing them that's what I'm doing I'll
tell you they got some [__] clothes
in there though they got some decent
clothes
you know if you just adjust your ego
down a little bit they got some decent
clothes in Walmart like you could make
it work
you know if you maybe if you just
[__] spend a little more money on
your pants no no you know what you got
it this is what you got to do if you're
gonna [__] go
cheap on something you can't do anything
near eye level you can't you can't get
away with a cheap shirt
you know what I mean you just gotta buy
a real nice shirt then the rest of it
can look like [__] but you have to be
charismatic to keep people looking you
in the eye because the second you start
losing their intention your their
attention you know and they start
looking down at the guy like why am I
looking at this [__] why am I
talking to him right they're gonna see
your shoes that's going to be over
and they can be like this [__]
shops at Walmart
he goes down to Wally World
[__] we all do we all go down there to
buy [__] an eight pound box of
[__] Wheaties we all do that [__] but
this guy actually goes down there and
buys the shirts
and I know what you're saying right now
Bill why are you making fun of people
who can't afford to shop anyplace else
other than Walmart and there's a simple
answer to that they're not in the room
with me right now
okay they can't do me any harm
and I am unbelievably tough on my
podcast I'll [__] trash anybody
um
[Music]
you know my dream is is that people who
wear Walmart clothes climb over the
walls of gated community someday and
they just start murdering bankers and
heads of Corporations
okay and then in the fight
everybody dies
so then you weed out your mouth
breathing racists
okay
and their spawn
and then you get rid of the guys up top
and then what you got in the middle is a
bunch of regular [__] people don't
want to get [__] with they're willing
to get up
go down the street you know
sell some apples come home right
that's what I do in my dream world I
have no idea what I'm talking about how
much [__] that I just throw at you
that was good 18 minutes of your life
you're never getting that back how do
you feel you're getting through the
traffic when are you listening to this
I'm open the volumes fine I know the
last couple weeks every once in a while
the volume gets bad it sounds fine to me
did I just spell Libya l-y-b-i-a I think
I did
Libya
who's that guy from Libya I don't know
who he is he ain't from here I think we
should bomb them
being a fan on on my own panel now
um all right let's get just a little bit
of advertising for this week
oh by the way I got to talk to you guys
about Blake Griffin I like Blake Griffin
I enjoy watching the guy play basketball
but it is impossible for me to do that
when I'm sitting next to [__] Paul
verzi or Jason lawhead they [__]
trash thing no matter what the guy does
no matter what he does he [__] dunks
on somebody ah yeah the guy got there
late that was more of the pass I did it
on some second string guy
Chris Paul does something they're
[__] jerking off I'm not saying Blake
Griffin's as good as is Chris Paul but I
mean you know the man is wildly
entertaining he is electrifying he
[__] is Dunked On Everybody in the
goddamn League get off his back
they're acting like he's Joe Barry
Carroll out there like they wasted a
bunch of [__] money that guy he he's
helping to put the Clippers on the map
you could [__] walk up to a Clippers
game
before that guy came I didn't give a
[__] about that Darius miles guy doing
the [__] antenna thing that's the
closest they ever came to anybody giving
a [__] about him right
Billy Crystal deserves a goddamn Sports
Medal of Honor for the amount of games
that he has sat through that guy said
[__] the Lakers and everybody else that
goes now I'm going with the Clippers
guys going he's contrarian you know by
the way did I mention I I do you guys
have you guys been watching The
Comedians yet
[__] great show and and the the pilot
episode
that pilot episode where they're trying
to get that show off the ground the way
they did that that's pretty much almost
exactly
just the the the conversations putting
two guys together that don't want to be
together but they they where their
careers are at they kind of have to be a
half big [__] concept a bad [__]
meeting you're talking to your manager
you gut's saying don't do it you end up
[__] doing it I mean the way they
executed that in the pilot was just it
was off the charts 10 10 out of 10. as
far as old freckles is concerned but
anyways Billy Crystal's been going to
these Clippers games I remember I I went
I went to a
Clippers games at the old LA Sports
Arena
he was there the black dude from A
Different World remember the guy who
wore the glasses probably had some weird
name
for his character that [__] killed
his career
like cockroach you know anytime you get
one of those names you're [__] done
right Doogie not Doogie he actually got
out of it Jesus Christ how the [__] do
you pull out of the mud Doogie
[Music]
um
Urkel you [__] cockroach you [__]
it's another one
Screech get done
if anybody is getting into the acting
game I will tell you this right now if
you [__]
do turn it down
if your character just has a nickname
you [__]
you [__] unless you have the the the
talent to start writing your own [__]
and producing your own [__] then you can
get out of it you can get out of it but
your whole [__] life you're done
right am I out of my mind
ow go [__] yourself I don't know I don't
know what I'm saying here anyway so
anyway so I go to the LA Sports Arena
it was Allen Iverson's rookie year
and I went down there
um to watch a game and Biggie Smalls was
in the crowd
and that was the trip within like five
days he was dead on that trip and I
[__] walked right by him
and he sort of had like these security
guys around him but he's just sort of
standing there hanging out and I
remember that thinking like wow I guess
that whole East Coast West thing is uh
West Coast thing is over but anyways
Billy Crystal was there
um the [__] am I talking about I'm
getting back so last night we're at the
bar and I'm sitting there trying to
enjoy the game and we got into this
[__]
we got into like three of the loudest
Sports arguments I just remember seeing
the bartenders in Knoxville just sitting
there laughing at us as we're screaming
at each other about [__] that they
didn't even care about
I remember one point this guy came up he
had a Red Sox shirt on and versus he
just goes
because how your Red Sox fan down here
and the guy goes I'm from Boston and
then you know [__] the Yankees and then
they get in this big fight
and then in the end versus going hey
what the [__] you guys yelling at me for
it's like version you started with the
guy and he goes no I didn't he walked up
to me and said hey [__] the Yankees
it's like Bob you're not wearing
anything that says Yankees on it you
started with him this guy's wearing a
Red Sox t-shirt
and he'd gone no I didn't you know that
level drunk you out where you just
[__]
you ignore everything all types of logic
um
so all I'm trying to do is enjoy it and
these [__] [__] they won't get
off Blake Griffin's back I mean I'm out
of my mind thinking oh we're not saying
we're not saying he's not a perennial
All-Star we're not saying that you know
he he's not he's not a good player we're
just saying that he he should be doing
more
it's like I don't know what you just
listed was pretty [__] impressive
wasn't it
oh [__] no all right let's let's do a
little bit of uh
let's get back to the [__] I'll tell you
this right now man I I one of the most
depressing places I've ever been to is
the U.S Airway
terminal connecting out of Charlotte
North Carolina
I was taking the red eye in oh my God
the [__] Humanity
that I saw
oh my God people just sitting there
you know
guy comes in with the I've been smoking
[__] cigarettes my whole life you
know with the tubes up his nose carrying
an oxygen tank somebody else sitting
there you know with a plate of nachos
writing right in a lap
beautiful girl just sitting there
killing herself just eating poison
everybody just poisoning themselves it
was like a fight it was like this
like this mass suicide that was going on
as I sat there in the terminal not
nobody making a [__] quality Choice
everybody just choosing misery in the
future
don't even get me started with the
[__] shoes
I was really that was like going wow man
this is this this is flying to Savannah
then I realized like nah you know some
of them are going to other places
it was really depressing
you know that's how that tastes you know
was coming to a close but then you know
the wonders of the road next thing you
know
I walked to a bar and I'm with Jay and
I'm getting a ride home from a gay guy
in a kilt I mean you know you always
hold out hope that it's gonna turn
around
[Laughter]
if he's listening thank you for the ride
and thank you for putting the beer in
the [__] paper cups it was it was
tremendous what a night right
oh so we ended up going uh we ended up
going out
to this Speak Easy right you know which
is you know it's just a Fame thing right
I had a little
key we met these two [__] women they
worked for like the uh Savannah
PD or whatever so I will get you in
right so we all [__] head over there
and we're sitting in this bar they're
making some good drinks and everything
and I wish I had these two ladies on the
podcast because I was just grilling them
I was like what is what is the [__]
weirdest
I go don't tell me any of the sad ones
when people are calling the cops give me
the weird ones the weirdest one this one
woman told me was
somebody said that their neighbor was
jerking off and they could smell the
semen
and she goes you know okay so what do
you mean like is he standing in the
window
can you see him she goes no I can't see
him but I can smell it I can smell it
through the walls
and they had to send somebody over there
so when he goes all right you can smell
it I got to tell you
ma'am I don't want to start an argument
here but I cannot smell any jizz
you know I think you have a wonderful
home here and maybe you ought to get
some medication
um
but anyways uh so thank you to everybody
who came out to Savannah by the way and
everybody who came out to Knoxville the
[__] theater I played in Knoxville I
think I said Ralphie May did a special
there and I can see why it's one of the
most beautiful theaters I've ever been
to it was um the Tennessee theater
built in 1927-28 you know this is
unbelievably gorgeous place where you
used to go down to watch movies
you know
I swear to God if I could be alive back
in the day like I think I would go back
to when they first built a lot of these
theaters that I played in just to watch
movies
knowing everybody gets dressed up it's
like a real big [__] deal they have
this giant Wurlitzer organ and I forgot
to look for the thing
and find out where it was they got it
refurbished send it out to some Maniac
in Reno that redid the whole goddamn
thing he's like a
he's like the guy I guess if you're
gonna have your [__]
giant Wurlitzer Oregon redone and um
the crab was uh was phenomenal you know
it was hilarious
was we were [__] uh
on the way there
law had such a big basketball fan he
wanted to [__] um
he wanted to do uh he wanted to go see
like the Tennessee Volunteers trophy
cases see Pat summitt's
you know trophies like women's
basketball that's like how psycho into
[__] basketball he is
and uh he ended up he ended up doing
this Pat Summitt joke on the bus
that had us die and laughing but like
verse he goes dude you got to do that on
stage and I said Jay don't do that on
stage don't do that on stage this is
like their [__] this is like their
female Jesus you don't do that don't do
a dementia joke on there and then what's
this verse he goes he should do it so I
said all right do it tonight okay and I
go and if it [__] bombs
all you got to do to save it is just it
was basically uh you know she's got
dementia it's like well if you saw that
much women's basketball over the years
you know you'd want to forget about it
too right a silly joke a silly joke but
if you say it in Knoxville it's going to
be a problem or if there's some [__] who
blogs
they'll they'll [__] flip out about
it and where my grandfather has dementia
and you made me sad Monday Morning
podcast t-shirt right and then all of a
sudden there'll be a controversy right
[__] baby seals starving to death
washing up on the [__] sand
they're gonna [__] give a [__] about
a joke somebody told Knoxville so
anyways so he was supposed to go out he
was supposed to go out there and just do
the [__] joke and if it bombed I'd go
just say hey I gotta be honest with you
you know first he said don't do it the
first he said do it burst said don't do
it I learned something here next time
listen to the headline or something cute
like that so he gets to go doing it and
he does that [__] first
going I don't know I said this joke on
the bus and I don't know I don't know if
I should say and the crowd's like come
on saying like he totally got him into
it
uh bug me because then it ended up
working and then he said verse he's
right it's like no you well once you did
the [__] UNICEF speech before the
joke
you know
you're almost questioning their goddamn
comedy manhood about whether they're
going to laugh about it or not but uh
anyways I'm just breaking their balls
we're having a good time out here so hey
Chattanooga people if you listen to this
today
let us know what there is to do out here
I never been here this is [__] cool
this tour because I've only overcome
been to Nashville and um
we actually drove up from Savannah on
the bus
it was so beautiful at one point going
through some of these um national parks
I was actually sitting up front
felt like John Madden on my way to Green
Bay for a game or something I was
sitting up there absolutely
Eastern Tennessee
southeast of Knoxville [__] God's
country
I'm telling you
I'm telling you if you can just deal
with them [__] Hillbillies out there
and you know every once in a while
somebody's gonna they're gonna be coming
for you you know I don't know what goes
on out there
um
I could never get Nia to live out there
she's a city girl you know what I mean
the way I get nervous on a subway she
gets nervous when she sees the woods
so uh you know the deal
you know who's going to make who more
miserable she's gonna make me more
miserable she wins so we stay in the
[__] City
stay in a city in a state where we're
going to be out of water in a year
how funny is it that I just put in an
Immaculate bathroom
at my house
spent all my [__] money on it
didn't spare any expense what was
already probably not going to make my
money back because they're just going to
look at it as square footage anyways and
I added no square footage to my [__]
house
um
but at least I had this great [__]
shower you know
and now we're going to be out of water
and once again nobody seems to be uh
alarmed by it nobody seems to be talking
about it like what what exactly is going
on
you know
population seals washing up [__]
running out of water
everybody just stay in the course I
think that's the game plan
I think that is the game plan you just
[__] act like everything is fine
and then one day you just take that
asteroid to the face and it's over maybe
that's the way to do it I'm starting to
give into it you know [__] it
you know y'all you can't do anything
about it what [__] you gonna do
you know you're gonna do you go kill
yourself Pig put it on spit
you won't dig a hole we gonna cook a pig
today I want to go to a [__] pig
picking down here
oh by the way uh when we go to New
Orleans uh the Pelicans are playing the
[__] Warriors come out and play yay I
think we're gonna try to go to the game
we got a day off down there how [__]
cool is that um but anyways I absolutely
love Knoxville man
um and I have to get back there again
the crowd was awesome have got to get
back there for a game
um and I was asking them what game to go
to and everybody was oh you know go to
the Tennessee Georgia game uh they play
Oklahoma next year that'll be a good
game and then this [__] Old Timer
came up to me and he's like game you
want to go to is the Alabama game and I
was just like right there all right
that's the game I'm gonna go to why
wouldn't I go to it
that might be my goal I'm gonna go to
what every SEC team when they play
Alabama and root against Alabama because
it's just it's just so much fun to root
against those [__] guys
and scream the dream Ends Tonight you
know why Bill why do you give a [__]
about it I really don't I just like
being a [__] I'm telling you guys I'm
gonna retire and I'm gonna buy a house
in Alabama that's my game plan that is
my exit strategy
you know God willing we still have water
when I retire somehow in L.A and my
house is actually worth something and it
hasn't turned to dust I am then going to
go out I'm going to buy me a spread I'm
maybe Eastern Tennessee
you know I'll be far enough Inland that
those [__] hurricanes will slow down
you know maybe every once in a while
there's a microburst and the trees lay
down but I'm inside I have a nice brick
house brick house all right let's get to
some of the questions here uh
for this week oh by the way um for the
for the Thursday Thursday afternoon uh
Monday Morning podcast just before
Friday
um if you would like you know stuff that
you want me to talk about articles for
me to read videos questions any of that
[__] you do it through Twitter and have
the hashtag t a m m p
Tango Alpha Mike Mike Papa
sorry
anyways
um just hashtag is that and I'll [__]
scroll through it two seconds before I
start and you'll get to listen to me
read out loud all right factory made
diamonds
okay Bill this is a follow-up from
Thursday clip where you answered a
question about real diamonds versus fake
ones and whether or not women should be
cool with the factory made ones uh
please ask listeners to go back and
check it out if haven't already all
right we'll go back and listen to that I
guess it was last week I don't even
remember talking about this [__]
uh uh a uh big billy dildo
I was listening to your clip
um
you replayed on the just checking it oh
well from last week oh that's why
because it was it was a throwback clip
from last Thursdays
just checking in on you Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
Morning podcast
um he said I know what this magical
stone is
all right I'll tell you the name but you
can choose to skip over it if you want
if you don't want the secret to get out
it's called a
I can't even say it moistanai
m-o-i-s-s-a-n-i-t-e it's not actually an
exact Diamond replica but it looks
identical to everyone that isn't trained
to know the difference the good news is
that your secret amongst amongst dudes
can be safe the only way to tell the
difference is if you take it to a
jeweler to figure it out if it's a dude
they're not going to [__] rat you out
if it's a chick well then you got a wild
card on your hands but there's nothing
you can do at that point I just no dude
men who work in jewelry stores are also
[__]
because they're going to want because
they're going to be like oh yeah you
bought you a fake one and because they
know that the woman's gonna go home and
[__] lose her [__] and the guy's
going to come back with his tail between
his legs
bringing a goddamn bag of cash to buy a
real one
um I'm gonna say okay so I can't I can't
even pronounce it moist moist cyanide
um he wrote it all basically in lower
case letters so I don't know where to
accent that word it's
m-o-i-s-s-a-n-i-t-e for guys who
need to buy their woman an engagement
ring but you don't want to blow a bunch
of money on diamonds just get him one of
this and they'll never know
that's actually a great thing too to see
if you get a gold digging [__]
she actually goes down and checks it out
like immediately to see what it's worth
it's like you already [__] leaving me
what are you doing here right
um
all right he said I just bought one for
my girl last week actually I looked up
the exact Diamond equivalent and it was
between 6 500 to 7 Grand just for the
diamond I paid 750 bucks the best news
is that my girl is totally on board with
this idea and her idea was to pocket the
extra to go on a badass honeymoon yeah
absolutely and then if somebody [__]
goes you know give me a [__] diamond
ring of your life you just give it to
him there you go
is Christ
that's [__] brilliant
you know what you should have
counterfeit cash in your wallet too
just walking around everything fake I
love this by the way you know made up
that thing about spending three months
salary on a ring the [__] Diamond
companies of course they did they had a
whole marketing campaign around it so
they're really [__] you over on on
top of the fact that they have a [__]
Monopoly so they can charge whatever the
[__] they want for real diamonds it's a
total sham anyways just wanted to spread
the word and let other dudes know that
there is an alternative that makes both
the girl and your bank account happy go
[__] yourself you know what the more I
hear about all of this stuff
the best thing ever it's got to be real
estate you know what I mean you can walk
up to it you can touch it you can live
in it obviously if you got a building on
it that's just got to be the way to go
you know [__] stock market I have
shares in this oh yeah where are they
you got them in your pocket
you know I am a firm believer of
um investing [__] that you can just in
[__] that you can walk up and touch but
now with the diamonds I don't know
the whole Diamond game now if you if you
buy into the diamond game now you have
to hope that the the people at the top
the evil doers actually uh keep that
Monopoly because if they don't
and you get free enterprise going on
there and then what do you have you get
like Sprint starts digging for diamonds
right
no Kieth and all these other [__] and
then what happens you gotta you got a
[__] storm on your hands
I swear to God people I'm gonna buy an
apartment building I'm gonna become a
slum Lord that's what I'm doing
I'm gonna buy apartment buildings fix
them up rent them out to people and then
I'm gonna slowly back out
of this business I want to retire the
way Sinatra did the first time
that's my goal I don't know if I'll be
able to do it but I would love the way
he did it
he's singing this song and he just goes
Excuse me while I disappear was the
final long line of the sign of Jesus
Christ the final line of the song
the final long and assigned the final
line of the song There we go and um it's
for that Pat Summitt joke look at me I'm
already losing my mind here
um
and he just stepped out of the spotlight
this if he if he [__] left that way
come on man that's even better than if
Jordan left after he hit that shot
against Utah I know I've already talked
about this but I am obsessed with how to
get out of his business now
as I've hit the middle part of my career
I feel 23 years ago I was 23 and 20
almost 24 23 years from now I'm going to
be 70. just like that boom [__] over
what am I going to be doing huh
70 years old
you're either a legend at that point and
they put you out to pasture in [__]
Vegas
or you're on cruise ships but either way
either way they're like let you you just
stay right here there Grandpa and we'll
bring the people to you
[__] that
I'm gonna buy a bunch I'm gonna become a
slumlord
I'm gonna buy a bunch of [__]
apartment buildings
in the middle of nowhere
and I'm gonna buy a white on white suit
put on some weight and just look like
Boss Hog right a red-headed [__] Boss
Hog and I'm gonna walk around a white
hat
you know and a big cigar that I never
liked that's what I'm gonna do
there's actually some people you know
who had a great [__] retirement out
of this business the Smothers Brothers
from what they told me at the Orleans
Casino
both of those guys they started their
own uh Winery
and uh they have their own Vineyard and
all that type of stuff and they got that
thing going up where it was making
enough money
dude you know what's so cool about them
when they retired they didn't even tell
people they were retiring they just did
their last show and they just left
total [__] Class Act no begging no
hat in the hand
no [__] crying no being broke they
had their money they had a good [__]
time they were done with it they left
and now they're sitting on a [__]
Vineyard
Jesus Christ you [__] tell somebody
let me ask you this what's your guys
game plan if you wait what's your
fantasy my fantasy is that I somehow
[__] I don't know have enough money
in real estate rental properties or
something I don't I'm just spitballing
here right that you're actually making
as much in rent as you were doing your
job so then you can quit your job and
just seamlessly walk over to that you
just be like yeah I'm not working
anymore
you know you got all your buildings paid
for you got all your things rented
everybody's cool I know this isn't going
to happen this is a fantasy and then the
check just comes in right you [__]
you go live in the middle of [__]
nowhere
where it's cheap as hell no property tax
no nothing
get a giant ass [__] TV all the
sports packages right
get yourself a [__]
on how to eat vegan or some [__] so you
stay in shape
I'm telling you
then every night you just get shit-faced
be [__] tremendous
tremendous that's what I want to do I
got to do it like that I can't be like
these athletes that I see that go around
[__] acting like jerk offs their
whole career then they're like oh [__]
I'm in my final contract
what am I gonna do and then they just
keep playing and playing and playing
[__] try on half the [__] jerseys
in the league that ain't gonna be me
you know just like Paulie and Good
Fellas that guy's gonna die in jail okay
that ain't gonna mean they ain't gonna
be me hey smart enough right
hope that didn't hurt your ears like it
just did mine all right let me uh get on
to the next thing here
um all right ditched by a lady all right
uh dear old Billy freckles I had a date
tonight with a lady and the plan was to
go get dinner and then see a concert she
was really cool and we went out to a
good restaurant near my apartment dinner
went well I was making her laugh Etc and
after I paid the check I told her I had
to use the bathroom she said she would
she'd wait right outside the restaurant
so I went in and did my thing but when I
came out I couldn't find her
I had only taken a piss so it's not like
I was taking a long time in the bathroom
I called her and it went straight to
voicemail
then I waited around and texted her and
she said that she had to leave because
her friend's boyfriend had just broken
up with her and that she needed to go
back to the apartment right away
oh Jesus Christ really she couldn't wait
to say goodbye to you I asked her if she
couldn't have at least told me before
she left and she said she was sorry we
both have tickets to go see a concert
next week which we had planned uh before
we planned tonight but I think it's just
going to be really awkward and I don't
want to do uh and I don't know what to
do because I'm pretty sure she just
ditched me I would love to hear
your Boston accent give me some advice
thanks and go [__] yourself
um yeah you either got ditched or she's
unbelievably [__] rude but you know
you can't hit your wagon to this there's
no way there's no way you're putting a
baby in that
the [__] you have a baby you know when
all of a sudden you know she squirts it
out and you're like oh my God look at it
honey
all right she [__] takes off again
you can't have that
she's she I don't know I don't know what
her [__] deal is but why what all I
need to do right now right now okay you
and this woman it's [__] over okay
and your your best hope if you still
want a banger is to stick by your guns
that you that you don't put up with this
[__] that it's [__] over and just be
matter of fact just say no that was
really rude and it was also very
immature if you weren't having a good
time you should have just said something
um no no no no my girlfriend Bo and then
and then on top of that you lie to me I
mean I'm actually glad that all of this
happened because I was able to see
you know that you're not the kind of
person that I would want to be in a
relationship with
you know
that [__] with them wait a minute
he's not mesmerized by my [__] anymore
right
next thing you know she's riding you
these are all just fantasies people I
don't know if there's any of this shit's
true
um all right so wait does she have one
ticket and you have one ticket
I don't know what I don't know what the
math is on the ticket he said we both
have tickets to go to the show well
here's the deal if you have both the
tickets
then you just take somebody else
um
yeah and I don't even think you know I
don't think you're over a phone call
either do you
or maybe you do yeah maybe you do I
would just call them just say yeah
listen I'm taking somebody ah no no no I
don't do that
if she has the tickets tell it if you
keep them
man I don't know
this thing is over Dude
that you don't need me you know what the
deal is it's [__] over
I gotta be honest it's [__] hilarious
that she just left I've done that I did
that when I was young and immature I did
that one time I met this woman and she
wanted to go out and go see this band
and so we went out there and
next thing you know she was up on the
stage dancing
while the band was playing pointing at
the crowd as if she was in the band
and
um I didn't have the emotional maturity
to wait till she got off the stage to be
like uh
yeah I don't know what that was it
seemed like you were enjoying it but
um it uh you know
I'm gonna go
and you know I I just left and I'll tell
you this I regret doing that because I
think it was really mean of me to do
that to her if that's how she likes
having a good time and likes going up
there
and dancing in front of a band that
she's in you know with in front of a
group that she's not in pointing at the
crowd is if she wrote the song if that's
what the [__] she likes to do then you
know
I guess you know I should have let her
do that I I was uh the very least I
should have been a man enough to [__]
walk away so
um
trying to think yeah I've had a woman do
that to me too
I had one more time was totally into me
it was over it was a lap she was gonna
bang me and I went up and I had a bad
set and I got off and she was gone
I bombed so bad
that a woman who was willing to have sex
with me thought better of it and this is
the best part it was a festival and it
was only a 15-minute set
in 15 minutes
15 and I have to think that halfway
through my set because I got off stage
she was gone so about seven minutes in
she did a 180 and just [__] walked
out so
it came back to me oh it always comes
back to you all right crime That Pays
Bill if you could get away with any with
a major crime
which would uh which would you be more
proud of a bank heist an art robbery an
assassination of an evil world leader oh
assassination all day long that was the
first thing I thought of
that was the first thing I thought of
that if you went to like the Last Supper
of every douche making people's lives
miserable you know
pretending like you know they don't have
they know those people who buy up
patents
so we can't get
um
energy you know electricity and gas and
all that [__] easier people who just
[__] get in the way of that progress
rape the environment [__] over poor
people all of those they all go to the
same meal
right and you just [__]
I don't know you're behind like some
photo or some [__]
with one of those
guns that they have on like a [__] I
don't know you ever see that one with an
Argo when they went down the runway and
they had that machine gun on that
[__]
Jeep whatever an M60 southern people
were tearing their [__] hair out
right now because they know exactly the
ones and they have sexy it ain't made an
F-16 years it's an m68 at this point
buddy
um
and you just [__] mow them down
you just mow them down and it's over and
then all of a sudden and then what bill
then who's gonna run us because I know
it's not going to be me then somehow
decent people all take those jobs and
make the right decisions and everybody's
[__] chill and there's enough for
everybody and everybody everybody can
relax right
that's what I would do
um I would never do an art robbery
because uh
I don't have an appreciation for a lot
of it especially if it's just a bunch of
scribbles
you know if it looks like a sleeve
tattoo or yeah somebody kind of colored
in your arm there buddy
I can kind of see a bird
spiderweb I don't know what else is
there
um a bank heist I don't want to do that
because uh that [__] with regular
people's money
you know art robbery then you know next
you know Butler's out of a job
yeah I probably shouldn't have said that
I'd assassinated an evil world leader
probably put me on some [__] list you
know
just added to the [__] audio that
they have in the [__] basement of the
Pentagon
um yeah it all it all ends up you all
end up you know you just end up in a
worker Camp I think that's how it goes
from here on out all right roll the dice
dear bill
and my wife has a friend who we've known
for a long time and happens to be very
attractive
let me read this again my wife's
my wife's you have more than one wife
here buddy my wife has a friend who
we've known for a long time and happens
to be very attractive okay so you've
already rubbed one out to her
possibly thought about her while you're
banging your wife okay the other day
over a couple of drinks with my wife
she admits that she wants to experience
a threesome and she wants it to be with
us
oh Jesus
oh my God here we go here we go
Jesus we should have closed with this
question this this is a closing bid
right here
when my wife first tells me this you can
imagine my excitement but then she adds
the kicker her friend while confessing
um her desire for threesome adds that
she has genital herpes
[Music]
wow
I did not see that left turn coming
but she swears that it is dormant and
we're not at risk well how do you think
she got it
oh that's such a stupid thing to say
maybe she [__] some guy you know you
always have to [__] you know look out
for the women in these maybe she [__]
some douchebag scumbag have you seen
that [__] they got a billboard out in
LA
it says do you trust him and there's a
guy laying there with this Shifty look
on his face with this woman looking at
him HIV positive you know type of thing
they would never have a billboard do you
trust her
it's unfucking believable like you know
I saw one time one of these magazines
right
where it says uh you know
reasons women cheat top 10 reasons women
cheat in the top eight out of ten was
were because of God was something the
guy was doing it's [__] unbelievable
anyways plowing ahead I am close to your
age so I ask you do you roll the dice
and go for it knowing that this may be
your last shot of the threesome or do
you play it safe and politely decline
the offer thanks and go [__] yourself
Pro in parentheses with protection uh no
dude you can't you can't do that
you cannot do that because right now
you're going to have a [__] threesome
all right even if you did that it's
going to make it weird between you and
your wife it just is as much as you're
going to try to be cool it's it's you
know you'll be cool with it she won't be
on some level she won't be you [__]
moaned a little too much with the other
one it's gonna be a [__] [__] show
all right and then on top of that you're
going to be reminded once a goddamn
month that you did it [__] that [__] all
of that all right
this is the deal all right if your wife
is willing to [__] do it that why
don't you do it with somebody who's uh
you know what I mean who doesn't have
any prior convictions here all right get
somebody with a clean slate
and um but um I don't know I'm sort of a
firm believer that you can't do that
with your wife
you do that with somebody that you're
not going to be married to I just think
uh
you know I don't know you ever see that
[__] when people like [__] drink too
much water
and they they die because like the the
walls of their cells like burst open
like that's what I think happens
when you have a threesome with your wife
and somebody else and it's basically the
lining to your relationship it's [__]
it's split it's done
it's over right and then it becomes then
her next thing's gonna be like well
let's do it again this time can we do it
with a guy
and uh well now I don't do what a
[__] guy because there's nothing in
it for me you know what I mean
what the [__] well there was nothing
[__] you you enjoyed it women can enjoy
other women
you know
then you get into that well that's a
double [__] standard ah go suck a
dick already leave me out of it I'll be
downstairs
you know you just you're just walking
into that whole [__] world
um
Jesus Christ but you know you got to
give it up to this woman for just being
totally upfront
I mean that
look there's something going on the fact
that you're excited by this and not
shocked and that your wife is willing to
do it
all right
you guys all seem like this is all
pretty loosey-goosey here
I don't know dude even with protection
they see you can still get it
dude [__] that
I don't know I I wouldn't do it I would
politely decline
and then ask for references if she
hasn't anybody she knows that doesn't
have herpes that wants to do it I don't
I don't know what to tell you here buddy
um
I would say don't listen to your dick
what would you tell a friend of yours if
they were in that position
oh my God
I guess the question I haven't asked is
how hot is this woman is it worth the
risk
I don't know you know what it is I I
just I can't get Beyond like what is the
conversation afterwards
okay
you guys bang first of all do not bang
in your own [__] house
okay you want to walk away from that
crime scene you understand
all right but then you got to be
thinking like okay then you get in the
car
no [__] that you got to have that
you know
That Awkward goodbye
like oh yeah that was
that was fun hopefully it went well
hopefully you don't get so excited sir
that you [__] uh you know
you get a false start there right let's
just hope the whole [__] thing goes
well and then you got you got that ride
home in the car
you know you both get in there you're
both trying to make you don't wanna
you don't know what to say so you're
just making noises like sitting down
like ah
radio
look they got a uh they got a new Costco
down here huh
you know God knows where the [__] her
head's at
and I'll tell you this right now there's
no [__] way she's not gonna ask some
questions
so you know like what are you thinking
right now
ugh you know my thinking I'm thinking
[__] you don't even start this [__] like
this thing I think you have to have that
conversation beforehand
if you're gonna do it you gotta say to
your wife all right here's the deal
we're gonna do this [__] but no being
[__] weird afterwards
all right
none of this did you like it did you
enjoy her more than me none of that
that's all off the table
all right
then what do you then then she's sitting
on it and then you know what she'd do
then she'll start crying
you have feelings
I'm just presenting the worst case
scenario
or even worse she [__] loves it
and wants to do it all the time and then
that just leads to just ah it's just
gonna lead to other [__]
It's Gonna Leave the other [__] I don't
know I don't know
who knows it could be fun
could be fun I just presented all the
hazards that could possibly happen who
knows man you could [__] go do it
bang bang boom you guys never [__]
talk about it again you get to check
that off the list you know you stare at
your dick for a good 30 to 60 days
nothing looks funny down there and you
know what you got away with it
just like Woody Allen in crime and
punishment right
you just sort of get away with it who
knows maybe it happens I don't know
all right and with that stamps.com
everybody
all right let's wrap this thing up here
with the final question
um I know what you guys have you been
watching hockey yes I have yes I have
I've been watching the Ottawa Montreal
series of course rooting against
Montreal
um Ottawa giving them a way tougher
series than I thought they were gonna
they played great they just um
Montreal is just [__] Relentless I
can't even talk I'm so [__] out of
its goddamn late nights
um they've just been so [__]
relentless
and um
I don't know man
I I they had to win obviously they had
to win the last game 3-0 I don't see
Montreal losing four straight although
if they do
um
I don't what I would what can I do next
week on the podcast if they somehow lose
four games in a row
I don't know what I'd do
it would just be the greatest thing ever
I would truly enjoy it but then I would
get nervous because we did that we blew
a three games to none lead against March
against the Flyers and then the next
very next year
we won the Stanley Cup
so I hope that doesn't happen I hope
they don't lose four in a row
do I I don't [__] know what am I
talking about all right mother herb dear
Billy bong rip
um Monday is 4 20. and I know the
Thursday podcast is now designated
towards Good Vibes man well the Monday
morning remains your Bleak outlook on
Humanity it really does however in the
spirit of the holiday can you please
tell us something crunchy about yourself
I don't even know what that means
perhaps a time when you connected with
nature or saw the human race as one or
in the least tell about a song or movie
you saw hi that was awesome
I love you love Nia this guy wrote this
when he was high love both you guys man
um I do I always seen the human race as
one I've always seen it that's why it's
so [__] depressing to watch the [__]
at the top do what they're doing that's
why my fantasies to take all of them out
and then people who are actually
responsible going and do the job and
they fix the world and I don't have to
do anything after I'm done pulling the
trigger and my life is totally easy
maybe that's selfish I don't know what
it is
maybe I'm an idealist you want me to
tell you something crunchy about myself
it's not enough that you know that I
make pies
huh
from scratch
all right you know what I have a lemon
and lime tree in my front yard
all right
and I get excited
when I walk out there and I get to pick
them off the tree
you know and then I bring them in the
house and I go you know what I'm gonna
make a key lime pie out of this
and then I come back later and I
realized that I forgot to tell my wife
and she's [__] used the limes that I
needed
see it's still going to go back to
something Bleak you know because that's
what life is it's there's a there's the
balance man you know what I mean man
it's like you know when life gives you
lemons your wife's gonna eat them man
and it's just you just got to be all
right with that man you just gotta look
down at your toes wiggle them in your
sandals and just kind of wait for the
other ones to grow man you know
um how was that was that fine
was that okay
something crunchy about me how about the
fact that I'm going out to all these
tertiary cities yes I just did use that
word did I pronounce it correctly I
don't think so
how about that how about I like going
out and [__] hanging out with the
people afterwards I actually enjoy
people on a one-to-one basis if they're
not [__]
right you know what you got me sir I
think you stumped me
I don't know that I have anything
crunchy
no
sorry
I tried
what do you want from me
baby seals washing up on the [__]
beaches killed me this week is that
crunchy enough for you
it's made me not eat fish the whole
[__] week I think I might be done
with fish I'm done eating animals that
we can't grow you know
breed or whatever
even then I think it's I don't know I go
back and forth with if it makes me a
piece of [__] if I eat [__] animals
or if you know they would have gotten
eaten anyway and what the [__] would a
cow be doing
if we didn't have a fence around it it
would be walking around like a big slow
dope and it would get you know there'd
be a [__] mountain lion around his
neck within two seconds
just hang in there slowly suffocating
the thing well we got the decency to
have that ceiling gun hover over its
head
and knock them out
so you can get yourself a prime goddamn
rib I know there's a lot of questions I
like that angle man try to draw out the
crunchy side of me that made me really
uncomfortable that was a nice feeling
every once in a while you got to get out
of your comfort zone all right that's
the podcast for this week go [__]
yourselves I'll check in on you on
Thursday